hello everyone I hope we're all having a
great Sunday and if not after seeing the
star brilliancy you just might this game
was played in 1972 it was a very strong
tournament held in Sukhumi and while tal
really had to had to get a great score
here to be able to play in the Chess
Olympiad in Skopje in 74 and well towel
did play a brilliant tournament and with
this tournament tells undefeated streak
started that he had with 84 undefeated
games and well a mark time and have also
played in this tournament he was still
recovering from his terrible loss
against Bobby Fischer in the 1971
candidates that six to zero loss and
time on have actually got third place in
this tournament and he might even get a
shirt first with Tull but the young 19
year old Alexander Billy ascii defeated
time enough so it was a pretty pretty
strong tournament but al was managed Tom
managed to win it and this game he's
playing against the Hungarian
international master Corolla confi who
was actually named grandmaster after his
death but the game is quite quite
amazing as Tom finds a brilliant
brilliant Bishop sacrifice and well his
opponent actually ruins the game by not
playing the best defense but we'll get
to that
so let's see the game home fee is white
and it all has the black pieces we are
efore so Tardos for c5 the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d4
seek after sandy for Knight captures and
v4 and v6 the time ah no variation
Knight to c3 a6 Bishop to e2 Queen to c7
F for b6 Bishop to e3 Bishop to e7 Queen
to d2 preparing queenside castle Knight
to f6 and we have castles by hon feet
and tall exchanges so one piece in the
center not capture sandy for Bishop
captures and e4 and e5
bit should be back to e3 and the towel
goes for his expansion on the Queen side
he plays b5 home fee goes F captures and
e5 we have d capture
five and now 92 d5 and although this
seems like like a good move for white it
will a towel pro otherwise topple his
knife capture sandy five we have a
catcher sandy five and Bishop to d6 and
with this Bishop to d6 move tell
prevents the spawn from ever going any
further and well this spawn will will
give a lot more trouble to white then it
will to black we have g4 humphy goes for
the kingside expansion Bishop to b7 and
the Kings to be one moving the King away
from this c-file tile castles King side
and we have Bishop to f3 and in this
position home he probably should have
went for something like h4 or or even
Bishop to d3 Bishop to d3 might
definitely be a better idea
going for that h7 and the top can't
really capture the d5 point if it goes
for Bishop at 77 you get Bishop captures
on h7 would check and picking up this
well Bishop on d5 so Bishop to f3 might
have been might have been better
definitely okay so after talk I sold
home he played Bishop to f3 with the
idea of playing Bishop to e4 next going
for h7 we had a 5 by tau further
expanding on the Queen side now Bishop
to e4 and well you can see that this is
losing a temple for nothing better to do
immediately would have been much better
tile goes for b4 and we have Queen to g2
and well it seems like home fee is well
he is preparing something on the Kings
side but it mostly appears that he's
over protecting this d5 pawn which
usually is a good idea but not not in
this game
a 4 by tau and the Queen to h3 humph is
not threatening checkmate on h7 but this
isn't really that big of a threat
g6 is played and well here probably
every player immediately would go for
Bishop to h6 would an attack on the rook
and then prepare some ideas maybe how to
get your Queen to f6 and go for some
checkmating ideas but home phase playing
against al and he doesn't want to go for
this he plays the bishop to see one
getting the bishop to help
with the defense of the king towel plays
Bishop to a6
we have rook H 2 e 1 and Bishop to c4 by
tau adding one more attacker to the
attack
we have rook to e3 so the rook can help
out with the defense and tile goes for
rook after c8 we have Queen - G - now
now
humphhh is preparing to push the H pawn
although it seems like all his previous
moves were really just losing tempos we
have b3 going for breaking open this
this pawn structure that is protecting
the White King C capture some b3 a
capture some V 3 and a capture some b3
and what you play here as black well tau
found found a brilliant move top plays
Bishop to e2 it's it's quite a well
quite a weird move as it doesn't seem to
be doing anything but you'll see what
tiles idea was now he's open up this
attack from the Queen to the c2 and also
he has this rockin H so covering the
entire a file and home for here played
actually Queen captures on e2 and this
is far not by far not the best move but
we'll get back to this position after I
show you the game and with this move
this is what I meant why Humphrey
actually ruined Dallas game table is
Queen to a5 now threatening Queen to a1
checkmate Rock the c3 now making room
for the King so he can escape Quinta a2
with check King has to go to c2 so King
c2 and our rook captures on c3 this is
why the Queen gave a check on a - not an
a1 so now this pawn is pinned so the
King has to capture it King captures
rook and c3 and top plays Bishop to b4
with check and well this is offering
another piece and well if you don't if
you don't accept the bishop for example
if you play something like King to c2
then you get rook to c8 with the check
and the white king has nowhere to go you
have to give up your Queen and after
Queen to c4 simply capturing with check
B captures Queen captures and again your
King has nowhere to go
to go to be won and you lose the bishop
on e4 with check this is completely
winning for towel so after Bishop to b4
check convict played the king capture
some before and out win 285 with check
forcing the King to go to see for King
BC for and now Queen to a6 with check
and this was one of the ideas of toss
Bishop sacrifice Bishop to e2 he wanted
home he's going to be on e2 and what the
King has to move and white loses a queen
so in this position Corolla home feel
resigned the game and it was it was a
brilliant victory for towel but like I
said I want I want to go back to that
position after towel played Bishop to e2
and I want to show you what tiles idea
was if home he actually played the best
defense here the best move for white
here is rook to c3 now attacking towels
Queen and it's very interesting now
tiles queen is attacked and also his
Bishop on e2 is still hanging so what
was tiles idea here here tiles idea was
Bishop captures on d1 sacrificing his
queen and c7 and caroli really ruined it
for not going for this rook to see to
remove rook captures on c7 and rook
captures on c7 and what do you play here
is white toss threat is pretty obvious
Roxy to a7 and rook to e1 checkmate and
if you try to defend this for example a
bishop - D - good idea of maybe Bishop
to c3 covering up well you do get rook C
to a7 now again threatening checkmate on
a1 and after King to c1 only move to
make room for a bishop to cover up the
check
you get rook to a1 with check bishop the
b1 and now Bishop captures on b3 and
again what do you play here is white
well Queen to f3 attacking this bishop
and also preparing some Queen f6 and
Bishop h6 ideas but you get Bishop to a2
and White has nothing to do here this is
completely winning white is losing
another piece here and well this is
simply too big of a material advantage
for for white
play so it would have been much much
nicer if Holmes played the best defense
but it was it was a pretty good game
nonetheless with this King capture some
before Queen a5 and now Queen to a6
check winning the White Queen but you
know it's always better to give up your
Queen than to win your opponent's Queen
but this is fine as well so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and if
you had a bad Sunday I hope this game
improved it and I would like to thank
Garret new vert for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can checked all my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon